how much can an iconic prop from a
slasher film get you at the golden
silver pawn shop how about a ticket stub
signed by a depressed boxer keep
watching to find out
in the season 10 episode captain rick a
man named jeff brings in what he
describes as a really old and hopefully
really expensive coin which he found
while cleaning out his grandmother's
house the brassy medallion bears the
image of king george iii of england on
one side with the message sailed from
england 1772 and a pair of ships named
the resolution and the adventure on the
reverse rick identifies those as the
ships of famed 18th century english
explorer and navigator captain james
cook one of the first europeans to set
foot in hawaii and many other pacific
islands okay who he was was he the
pirate from peter pan or something
rocked it speculating that this
medallion may be a cheap replica made
for gift shops rick calls in david vege
of ngc ancient a local coin expert
veggie identifies the item as being of
historical significance claiming that
cook had struck only 2 000 of these
medals and they were given to native
leaders in the pacific islands on his
voyages as a token of esteem jeff's
medal was held by captain cook himself
in 1772 and veggie estimated its value
at auction at somewhere between seventy
five hundred dollars and eighty five
hundred dollars before he came into the
shop jeff thought he might get fifty to
a hundred dollars but he walked out five
thousand dollars richer
evander holyfield and mike tyson are two
of the most famous boxers of all time
when they were both young amateurs they
participated in the 1984 summer olympics
held in los angeles holyfield was
competing for the us as a light
heavyweight while tyson was an alternate
without much to do except warm the bench
boxing super fan bill described how
tyson's head was despondent and took him
out to lunch to raise his spirit bill
got tyson assigned his ticket stub from
one of the olympic matches and then
managed to get holyfield to sign it too
when bill presents the double
autographed relic at the gold and silver
pawn shop he wants 500 for it corey
harrison calls in steve gratt the
principal authenticator at beckett
authentication services to verify the
item after analyzing the ink and
comparing the signatures to other old
tyson and holyfield autographs grad
declares the stub a winner and stakes
its value around two thousand dollars
while corey offers bill one thousand
dollars for the item the two guys reach
an impasse and bill walks away without
selling deciding to frame the ticket
instead
in a 2020 episode a man named dennis was
looking to sell off an old
well-preserved long gun one that leaves
rick and corey harrison scratching their
heads over its true worth corey is only
able to identify the french origins of
the firearm whereas rick immediately
realizes they have a boutique rifle on
their hands describing the gunsmith as a
rembrandt of guns and the first gunsmith
to really combine function and artistry
rick elaborates that boutique catered to
the wealthiest customers in the late
1700s and early 1800s dennis wants ten
thousand dollars for his treasure but
before offering any amount the
harrison's call in alex cranmer ceo of
international military antiques to
assess the value a visibly excited
crammer describes boute as the official
gunsmith of french king louis xvi and
later emperor napoleon after admiring
the rifles detail and ornamentation and
giving it a try on a shooting range he
estimates his potential auction selling
price at thirty thousand dollars dennis
ups his asking price to twenty thousand
dollars but rick eventually talks him
down to sixteen thousand dollars i now
own a fine boutain not that i haven't
always had one it took you 50 something
years to get one
in a season 10 episode of pawn stars a
guy named john enters the gold and
silver pond looking to sell off an item
that he won in a card game it's an
encased 1922 stamped silver dollar peace
emblem coin while jon asks for 20 000
for his coin rick harrison immediately
calls in an expert declaring the piece
one of the holy grails of american coins
david vaguey of ngc ancients arrives to
inform rick and john that this
particular coin was struck in 1921 part
of a campaign to bring back the silver
dollar this coin is significant due to
its extra high relief matte finish and
tremendous detail however these same
details were also its downfall as it was
too difficult to produce this design in
large quantities most of the original
run never circulated and was apparently
melted down leaving just a few in
existence a century later vege notes
that a coin in slightly better shape had
recently sold for more than one hundred
thousand dollars and he estimates the
value of john's coin at somewhere
between fifty thousand dollars and a
hundred thousand dollars after some
haggling a pained harrison buys the coin
off john for eighty thousand dollars a
man named jody enters the golden silver
pond claiming that he inherited some
personal effects from his late
grandfather which included a gold coin
bearing the royal crest of spain
according to rick harrison this is a
1715 spanish fleet coin specifically a
lima escudo minted in peru made from
gold mine by indigenous slaves during
imperial spain's colonial occupation of
south america the piece is hardly
uniform as things like purity and weight
of the gold were far more important rick
considers the coin exceptional and finds
that it consists of 27 grams of pure
gold jody wants two thousand dollars for
the heirloom but since the market had
recently been awash in fake spanish
fleet pieces harrison brings in his
spanish colonial coin expert a guy named
carl carl's analysis finds it to be
absolutely genuine and worth around 18
000
saying the coin was likely part of king
philip v's personal stash after some
negotiation jody persuades rick to pay
him 11 000 for it
probably the most famous part of the
1960 alfred hitchcock film cycle is the
iconic scene in which a criminal on the
lamb played by janet lee is brutally
murdered in a motel shower by the
disturbed norman bates portrayed by
anthony perkins the production certainly
went through a few bathroom related
props like shower curtains and a plastic
one found its way into the gold and
silver pawn shop on a season 13 episode
of pawn stars it's kind of creepy it's
even creepier
because it's signed by anthony perkins
the basketball player a man named mark
explained that he wanted in a contest in
san diego and got it autographed by
perkins in blood red ink after he gave a
speech about directing cycle 3 in 1986
mark ideally wants 400 to part with the
curtain but won't go any lower than 300
those terms seem reasonable to rick
harrison but to confirm its value he
calls in authenticator steve gratt the
expert confirms that the item was indeed
signed by perkins he puts its value in
the area of eight hundred dollars to one
thousand dollars more than double mark's
asking price after a little haggling
rick agrees to buy it from mark for 500
robbie the robot became one of the most
familiar and iconic mechanical men in
all of pop culture after its first
appearance in the 1956 sci-fi movie
forbidden planet designed in 1955 for
mgm by artist robert kinoshita robbie
would eventually appear in more than two
dozen movies and tv shows including the
twilight zone and the addams family a
client named stanley pops into the gold
and silver pawn shop carrying a robbie
the robot toy from the mid 20th century
still in its original box as stanley
explains to corey harrison and chumley
the toy procured at an estate sale was
produced in japan and is labeled
mechanized robot because mgm wouldn't
license out the rights to make name
brand replicas stanley wants two
thousand dollars for the toy in box but
skeptical of its authenticity corey
brings in johnny an expert on old toys
and owner of the toy shop johnny likes
what he sees the robot still works and
his battery compartment doesn't show any
signs of corrosion citing the big
secondary marker for such nostalgic toys
johnny figures the robot's value at 2
200
more than stanley's dream price after
some countering harrison buys the toy
for eleven hundred dollars
a young man named kevin heads into the
gold and silver pawn shop on a season 17
episode to inquire about selling a
helmet he bought at an estate cell the
former football player thought the item
was reminiscent of a simple helmet from
the sport's early days but after some
research found out that it's probably an
iron battle helmet from the anglo-saxon
era of european history chumley agrees
that the metal helmet could be up to
1400 years old made from thin iron and
weighing between five to eight pounds
the helmet is called the spang and helm
german for metal strip helmet kevin
hopes to get 750 for the piece but since
chumlee has no idea what it's worth he
brings in bob dodge of artemis testing
lab dodge notes how remarkable it is
that the thing lasted for more than a
millennium without oxidizing into dust
he uses an x-ray gun to determine that
it's made from the error-specific carbon
steel and suggests the one in a million
item belongs in a museum and it's worth
about fifteen thousand dollars chumley
and kevin ultimately brought her down to
ten thousand dollars
a woman named april seeks to sell an old
relic needing money for moving expenses
and a big screen tv she knows she's got
something pretty valuable during her
visit to the gold and silver pawn shop
in a 2010 episode presenting her 1602
shipwrecked dutch east india company
bell to rick and his father old man
richard harrison richard is instantly
skeptical that the item is worth much or
even came from a shipwreck claiming it
lacks enough corrosion to have been in
salt water for any lengthy period of
time it would have been good for
business had the harrisons made a
nominal offer for the bell since after
they called in their expert carl to
evaluate the bell they determined it to
be a genuine relic of the dutch east
india company which dominated world
trade for over two centuries carl
explains ninety percent of shipwrecks
occur in shallow water and it is highly
likely natives easily removed this bell
and brought it ashore citing its
worthiness of being in a treasure
auction catalog carl cites a cash value
of fifteen thousand dollars while
richard only offers a measly three
thousand dollars for the bell rick
eventually haggles with april to settle
at 7 200
while the house of faberge famous for
its faberge eggs was the most
prestigious jeweler in 1800s imperial
russia its main competitor was the
equally impressive house of bowlin
according to craig gottlieb of craig
gottlieb military antiques that's who
manufactured a medal that came across
the display cases at the gold and silver
pawn shop in a 2014 episode rick
harrison offers a substantial sum of six
thousand dollars to the client who
brought in the white eagle medallion
thought to be a centuries-old
gem-studded polish piece gottlieb
explains it's not really polish but
russian in 1795 poland was partitioned
into segments ruled by prussia austria
and russia and the latter took the white
eagle symbol of a polish order founded
in 1325 and combined with the russian
two-headed eagle it's a really neat i
mean this is 800 years of history here
this medal shows just how hard poland's
had it for the past 800 years that leaf
says the medallion was likely forged in
saint petersburg and that it's worth
thirty thousand dollars to forty
thousand dollars harrison's original
offer for the medal was far under its
actual worth and the new estimate forces
him to offer a lot more than he expected
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
pawn stars are coming soon subscribe to
our youtube channel and hit the bell so
you don't miss a single one
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you